what oh Richie's losing I think she's  losing again and look at the clock  situation that's what I meant yeah that  both sides will be blitzing out their  moves  what was this okay random stuff this  bishop B3 all of a sudden became a line  takes D6  so far  yeah  and Nema won already  looks like he just got a good position  and  is on fire now two out of two today he's  moving to plus three  Magnus probably rooting for him not to  show up on his board anytime soon yeah  that's tough decision for Magnus then  that's for sure but we we do know that a  lot of media attention on this scenario  yeah the media is waiting for this  okay Neiman climbing tough break for  Richie to lose with white I mean it's  not so easy to